okay so let's quickly let's quickly do
any table okay
so we'll do our 1/2 plus 1/4 so the
denominators are different in this case
right how do I change one or both of
these fractions so they'll have the same
denoted a want to suggest Brennan okay
so if you look at this guy right - and
for the differences well for double that
right so if I take this I multiply that
1 by 2 but if I change the top better
change the bottom as well right because
otherwise it could actually be a
different fraction so I multiply the top
of the bottom bytes - that gives me 2
over 4 okay now do your bread but just
before we actually say you know add them
together a half and two quarters right
these guys are linked does anyone
remember from last year what is it
called when really it's the same
fraction but it's like Claro looks
different wearing different clothes the
same size start to fatigue yeah
equivalent fractions very good you see
done a bit of an entree equivalent
fractions so if you were to have two
pizzas one of it was just sliced up a
bit and the other one was in quarters
okay it wouldn't matter whether you took
half of the pizza or two quarters the
pizza it's the same thing it's
equivalent okay and that's why we can do
this now they're on the same denominator
what can do with these guys now I can
yeah good now be careful by the way be
really really careful we just add them
but what we had is the numerators it's
the new race not the denominators so I'm
going to get two plus one
there's the numerators and then they're
denominated just stays the same but if
the other way you can remember this is
two ways the first way is remember what
is the denominator and what is the
numerator the Dominator is the size of
the pieces right how bigger the pieces
so if it's a hundred the pieces are very
very tiny it's gonna be
little little pieces the numerator is
how many pieces do you have so when you
add two things right the sizes stay the
same okay for instance if I put together
like just to get a pretty table if I put
together there we go okay so if I put
together one green markup plus another
green marker okay they don't become like
really really green markers they still
stay which they still stay the same
color right very good okay now in the
same way when you had two fractions
together the fractions don't change in
size but you add together that quantity
and that's the numerator so two plus one
of course is just three I say that's one
way to remember it
the other way is just to think it can
get a bit ridiculous if you added the
numerator and the denominator think
about this guy
uh-huh plus a half well then what a half
was half is its it's just one right it's
just you put the two halves together and
you get the whole back but what would
happen if I added the numerators and the
denominators you'd add the new raising
yet too and then you'd add the devotees
and get form but hold on a second
we just said we just said the two and
over four and one-half on the same and
I'm pretty sure that 1/2 plus 1/2 isn't
1/2 that's like my older brother trying
to give me a bad deal on like yeah sure
is how much you get this is your share I
think I've lost something here so you
don't add the denominators and the
numerators what would the right answer
be how do I get to one yeah okay we're
not doing any multiplication just yet
except for changing equivalent fractions
right I'm going to add the numerators
that'll be 1 plus 1 and the denominator
stays the same
does that make sense yeah ok so make the
denominators identical ok let's do a
second example and you'll see another
useful thing that you can do ok so if I
say
plus one and two fits okay and this is a
bit trickier right of course I want to
do this I want to make the denominators
identical but in addition to that like
this is quarters
this is fits even if I got them on the
same to note it is like this this one or
two pieces of it awkward to what we're
okay so I'm going to get rid of mixed
numerals where I can remember mixed
numerals are just another way of writing
even proper fractions okay so how would
we write 1 and 2/5 as an improper
fraction rather than a mixed new rule as
it is right now okay I can Rachel what
do you think ok 7 over 5 now just before
just before I get to 7 over 5 because
some of you see that immediately and
that's great but I know I look at this
and I sometimes muck up this son this
conversion process okay he's how I would
think about it remember I said to you
this is 1 and 2/5 1 and 2/5 so this is
really 1 and 2/5 do you agree with that
like I've literally just put the hand in
there okay now here this one I can
replace it with like I won I'm in 5th
circuit right so I can replace that one
weird 5 over 5 do you see that like
that's the equivalent fraction to 1 and
now you can see 5 plus 2 that's what
keeps you in the 7 that's where the 7
comes from ok any questions on that
conversion person said ok to get rid of
weeks new rules this is what we - now
I've got an improper fraction ok now
that that's that's that I can do this
make the denominators identical Lillian
why don't you give me a suggestion what
could I do
to each of these fractions I might give
us a little more space yeah
I can't very good
lowest common multiple we want the
lowest common multiple of both
denominators right the lowest number the
smallest number I can think of that you
can divide into four and five years 20
very good so to get to that I'll
multiply this one by 5 over 5 and I'll
multiply this one by 4 over 4 ok so
you're going to get 20s there and 20s
there does that make sense
ok so let's quickly do that ok so now
they're the same denominator and now
we're good to go I can just add the
numerators in the denominator stays put
ok that's 28 ok so we can see what's
going on there 15 plus 28 28 43 over 20
and you're finished you could if you
liked and on sometimes the question will
ask me to do this but I haven't um you
could see how it started with mixed
numerals you might like to put it back
as a mixed new rule that might be useful
to you ok so if I wanted to write this
as a mixed numeral how do I put it back
how do I do it in reverse
yeah anyone yes yeah very good
I want to figure out how many 20s can I
fit in 43 or whatever that denominator
is like if the denominator was 7 or 18
you think how many of those do I fit in
here in the interests you write once you
take out that 220-240 so you get left
with the 3 done